c'est fanny chouinard michel david
jonathan trudeau bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
loi 21 loin sur la laïcité de l'état le
gouvernement fédéral va donc participer
marc et monsieur trudeau vous l'avez pas
mal l'indiqué mais c'était plus clair
que jamais bon là on écoute monsieur
trudeau je l'aimais ti et réactions à
québec
nous avons des préoccupations par
rapport aux propositions qu'on fait le
au projet de loi du gouvernement
provincial et en temps au gouvernement
fédéral je pense que tout le monde
comprend que nous devons être là pour
protéger les droits fondamentaux de tous
les canadiens où qu'ils soient dans
notre pays
un fois que la cour d'appel a tranché
on va devant la cour suprême pour donner
nos ex nos opinions là dessus parce que
ça devient par définition un enjeu
national une fois que ça arrive à la
cour suprême du canada donc nous y
serons
dominy cela m'était donc au ministre de
justin trudeau qui avant même d'avoir la
décision de la cour d'appel dit qui va
aller en cour suprême pour contester la
loi 21 la loi qui interdit les cinq
religieux pour les personnes qui sont en
autorité c'est un manque de respect
flagrant de justin trudeau en valais
québécois puisque ont aussi qu'une
majorité de québécois sont d'accord avec
la loi 21 et donc justin trudeau vient
de moi je vais aller me mêler de ça je
vais aller contre la volonté d'une
majorité de québécois c'est un manque de
respect complet de sa part dit
alors stéphanie chouinard commencé avec
vous est ce que c'était pas écrit dans
le ciel dans parce que c'était pas de
télégraphier déjà que le gouvernement
fédéral allait se mêler une fois arrivée
à la cour suprême de ce débat
ouais ça on le savait déjà a demandé
maintes reprise notamment aux dernières
élections fédérales la question avait
été posée est ce qu'un gouvernement
fédéral libéral allait interjeter appel
sur la loi 21 et à toutes les reprises
monsieur trudeau ainsi que c'est 50 de
ses candidates avaient refusé de fermer
la porte donc on se doutait fortement
que si ça se rendait en cours supprimer
sauf si c'était pas mal écrit dans le
ciel que le gouvernement fédéral allait
demander à intervenir bon ben je l'avais
on n'est pas surpris monsieur legault
est fâché qu'est ce que vous lisez là
dedans ce qui me surprend de la part
d'un site rue dos et de le faire
maintenant je comprends pas pourquoi
effectivement la cour d'appel a pas
encore rendu son jugement alors lui déjà
rendue en cour suprême monsieur legault
bon au fait une crise d'indignation qui
était tout aussi prévisible que la
décision de monsieur trudeau d'aller en
cour suprême mais je soupçonne que ça
fait son affaire à la veille des
élections envoyé à prochaines élections
les jeux sont au rang sont pratiquement
faits au québec et il est vrai
adversaire de monsieur legault au cours
de la prochaine campagne dans mon esprit
ça va être monsieur trudeau il va
préparer la table pour son deuxième
mandat alors que ce soit sur la langue
sur la liste et sur l'immigration
je m'attends à ce qu'ils soient
passablement féroce à l'endroit du
gouvernement fédéral et je pense que
l'électeur allemand ça va être
avantageux pour lui il va vouloir mettre
en porte à faux les libéraux en envoyer
moi je demande pour les réunions
familiales à l'immigration présent
seulement tous les pouvoirs jonathan
trudeau comment vous avez décoder les
déclarations de la journée
bah essentiellement que la pandémie est
vraiment derrière nous comme ça que je
les décode je partage l'immense
sentiment de nausée profondeur d'une
majorité de la population qui décroche
de encore une fois c'est magique à
l'écouter on a fait deux campagnes
fédérales là dessus sur ces espèces de
jeu du fédéral qui a admis monde disait
que l'était pour contester on lille
vient de le confirmer comme celle raison
plus questionné sur le moment mais
c'est pas une surprise au même
titre qu on n'est pas surpris non plus
de voir la réaction de françois legault
et je note toujours patrice à chaque
fois dans des situations comme celle-là
françois legault vient vraiment
personnaliser les enjeux injuste dans
l'extrait qu'on a entendu le dit trop ou
quatre fois justin trudeau où il vit et
le personnaliser à justin trudeau cela
étant dit je pense que la lecture de
françois legault va être bonne à l'effet
que ça va être payant même pour lui de
faire des reproches à ce niveau là où
dans l'ain fédéral parce que moi j'ai
toujours pensé que les puits massif
gallois 21 s'expliquer de deux de deux
façons bien simple premièrement une
partie d'eux des citoyens qui auraient
moins de soif profonde de laïcité une
autre partie notre masse critique qui
veut juste passer à autre chose qui est
tanné d'entendre parler de ce débat là
or on avait l'impression qu'on était un
peu passé à autre chose ça nous revient
encore une fois plein visage bon
remarquez ça va être long là parce que
on n'est pas encore rendu à la cour
suprême loi 96 loi maintenant plus
projet loi depuis hier on écoute
monsieur lâm éthique il a aussi dit
il prend cet exemple mais aussi pour la
loi 21 dit que le gouvernement du québec
applique la clause dérogatoire comme
bouclier on n'aime pas ça
nous avons des inquiétudes sur
l'utilisation
après un petit de la clause dérogatoire
je me souviens des débats à l'époque
c'était supposé d'être le dernier mot
dans une dialogue entre les tribunaux et
les législatures est pas le premier mot
et quand cette employée
surtout dans une dans une façon on y
bosse quand cette employée comme le
premier mot ça coupe le débat politique
est comme la cour supérieure à noter sa
coupe aussi la révision juridiques et
les porcs dans une démocratie ce n'est
pas
ce n'est pas souhaitable
et ça ça pourrait être contesté être
soulevée ces familles chouinard
l'utilisation de la clause dérogatoire
comme parapluie avant cela mais tu dis
après une décision qu'on se soustrait à
la décision pour telle ou telle raison
politique mais avant ils n'aiment pas ça
ouais bon il ya cet ange lemée avec la
loi 96 il ya d'autres enjeux aussi qui
ne seront peut-être pas couverts par la
clause dérogatoire parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que certaines certaines certains
articles la charte canadienne des droits
et libertés qui ne sont pas sujets ti à
la clause dérogatoire et les
anglo-québécois ont aussi des droits
historiques qui ne date pas de la charte
mais bien de la loi constitutionnelle de
1867 et donc il y à un vaste champ
d'application de la loi 96 notamment
dans le domaine de l'accès à la justice
je pense qu'ils savent cerveau susciter
des débats intéressants ou la clause
dérogatoire ne s'applique même pas et
donc ça sera quand même assez
intéressant je pense de voir à quoi vont
ressembler ces décisions judiciaires
michel david et jonathan sur la loi 96
il dit par ailleurs on va être vigilant
le met donc on l'a aussi quand même on
fait des ports on avance c'est comme si
tu côté fédéral la parole avaient été
libérés ou si michel ah oui moi je
m'attends à ce que le gouvernement
fédéral intervienne éventuellement dans
le processus judiciaire à une étape ou à
l'autre probablement pas avant la cour
suprême mais parce que je pense que ça
va éventuellement se rendre mais
l'utilisation de la cour la clause
dérogatoire évidemment c'est moins
odieux je pense de l'introduire d'entrée
de jeu que d'attendre que la cour
invalide une loi est ensuite allé à
l'encontre d'un jugement de la cour
politiquement je pense que ce
politiquement voulait dire politiquement
c'est beaucoup plus délicat de le faire
et je pense que il alors
l'essor et d'autre part je pense que
monsieur legault en l'introduisant
d'entrée de jeu voulait faire une
affirmation presse et non seulement pour
protéger la loi mais pour dire écoutez
ce sont les
législatures les parlementaires qui ont
d'entrée de jeu le droit de définir les
règles et c'est pas la cour de venir
nous dire c'est un vieux débat c'est
celle là depuis que la charte est
introduite dans la constitution mais
c'est un débat qui a jamais été
commandés politiquement régler c'est
encore contestée qui est le patron en
définitive à ce qu elles ce sont des
juges sont élus ou les parlementaires et
on en voit encore une autre
manifestation ouais jonathan c'est un
des bocks là aussi qu'il regarde les
libéraux et les cas kyste sur le front
de la prochaine campagne les tâches que
les libéraux ont dit 'nous on est on est
contre l'utilisation de cette clause en
général l'ontt il dit clairement je sais
pas menti quand il était là mais en même
temps je le demande
de quel droit les ministres et la
mythique questionne les occasions se
serait pertinent ou non d'utiliser la
clause dérogatoire s'ils veulent le
contester devant les tribunaux s'ils
veulent qu'on veut contester certaines
dispositions de la loi les bras où ils
vont le faire et d'ailleurs on me dit
que la position on m'a confirmé que la
position sur le projet de loi 96 était
pour être analogue vraiment celle de loi
21 c'est à dire ils seront pas ceux qui
vont initier les démarches mais
assurément ils se feront entendre dans
le cadre d'éventuelles démarches donc
c'est le droit il le
plein et entier son jeu durant fédéral -
la seule chose qui m'irrite
particulièrement et déjà on le voit dans
certaines réactions de députés non
seulement du parti libéral mais même
d'autres candidats je pense entre autres
à scott atchison qui est candidat à la
chefferie du parti conservateur
c'est lorsqu'on fait vraiment carrément
de la démagogie moi je suis loin de
penser que ce projet de loi il est
parfait j'aurais pas quand je pense
qu'il répète bonifiés je pense même que
dans le temps il sera bonifié avec
d'autres mouture présentée soit par la
caq où il va seulement par d'autres
partis politiques mais de là à les
affirmer qu'on enlève des droits ou aux
anglais que les anglais ne pourront plus
la population et personne ne pourra plus
se faire soigner au québec et cetera et
cetera un peu comme on l'avait fait que
la loi 21 au niveau de 2008 et quand ce
n'est pas carrément des mensonges et ça
je trouve que ça vient accentuer le
clivage entre le québec et le reste du
canada stéphanie qu'est ce que j'en
pense et de sa de la couverture en tout
cas delà de l'interprétation
sur les soins de santé parce qu'ils ont
essayé d'être clair en disant ça change
rien pour les soins de santé qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la sq ont dit de
cette loi ailleurs
c'est difficile lorsqu'on rend dans les
débats linguistiques tant au québec qu'à
l'extérieur du québec on a souvent
tendance à avoir des positions très
parfois trop tranchées qui manque de
nuance et on voit qu'il ya des acteurs
qui tentent de profiter en dessous de ce
type de débat là donc malgré le fait que
le gouvernement tente est justement de
mettre les choses au clair on voit
qu'ils demeurent des craintes et ses
craintes leçons sont nourris par une
partie de la population anglo québécoise
par contre ce que je dirais c'est que
par rapport à certains débats qui ont
déjà eu lieu le projet de loi 96 a quand
même pas susciter les passions au canada
anglais comme ça a déjà été le cas si on
compare par exemple à l'adoption de la
loi 101 dans les années 70 on est très
très loin de du type de rhétorique assez
inflammatoires qu'on retrouvait dans les
globules duster et autres médias anglo
canadien ça ça demeure un phénomène dont
on parle mais de façon assez marginales
sont tout ouïe on n'est pas 77 michel
david
non non très certainement pas et la
réaction des communautés anglophone a
été assez virulente mais c'est aussi
l'accueil de la majorité francophone ce
point un débat qui a passionné beaucoup
à part la question du cégep il n'y a
rien de comparable mais si je reviens
aux
craintes exprimées par les anglophones
c'est pas juste fils aliens loi sur
l'accès aux services en anglais de santé
en anglais qu'il acquit pas changé par
rapport le projet de loi 96 et de façon
générale il ya une affirmation qui dit
que les services
devront être rendus en france est bon et
c'est avec l'exception de la santé la
sécurité la justice naturelle alors je
vois pas du tout
sur quelle base on se base en se fonde
pour faire des accusations pareil lisez
dans une chronique dans de voir ce matin
par la diffamation
ça y ressemble bon et j'ajouterais je
peux me permettre le fédéral pourrait
aussi s'occuper de ses propres plates
bandes en comment ça avance le projet de
la ministre petit pâté l'heure alors que
le fédéral s'est engagé lui même à
légiférer pour protéger la minorité
linguistique au canada c'est à dire les
francophones c'est un projet de loi qui
n'est pas encore qui n'est pas encore
adoptée dont on ne parle très peu qui
veut viser entre autres des organismes
fédéral à charte fédérale et quand on
regarde la situation quand on pense à
air canada de la façon que ça se passe
avec monsieur rousseau quand on pense au
conseil d'administration du cn et ses
terres terrain je pense que le fédéral
au décharge fouettée de son côté pour
protéger la minorité linguistique avant
de faire la leçon au québec un petit mot
là-dessus stéphanie avant de passer
l'importance que vous voyez au débat
conservateurs de ce soir ses fans un
petit mot là dessus sur le projet
fédéral
justement on entend des
pardons
lancer les consultations visant le plan
d'action sur les langues officielles au
plan d'action qui devra être entré en
oeuvre en 2023 l'année prochaine on a un
peu l'impression que le gouvernement
fédéral met la charrue devant les boeufs
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne se concentre
pas justement sur l'adoption de la loi
sur les langues officielles le projet de
loi c 13 qui est maintenant en deuxième
lecture mais qui ne se rendront
certainement pas une étude en comité
d'ici aux vacances d'été donc on imagine
très mal que ce projet doit être adopté
en 2022 si la tendance se maintient
alors qu'on parle déjà de nouvelles
politiques quinquennal alors que les
assises législatives sont vous sont pas
là on est encore dans la loi sur les
langues de celle de 1988 donc ouais du
côté du gouvernement fédéral on a aussi
effectivement les brûler
des bottes dernier débat en français ce
soir des candidats conservateurs pour
l'aide avant le jeu je prie pour que le
format le modèle soit pas le même que le
dernier débat anglais l'asec pouvant
table mais considérant les gens
s'attendaient à quoi puis est ce que c
est ce que c'est important je n'attends
tour de temps sa multi confirmé que le
format est différent on parle de neuf
thèmes avec 45 secondes par participant
pour évoquer une position de base et par
la suite ce sera des échanges ouverte si
on veut les échanges vers d'une durée de
4 minutes et il devrait pas avoir de
questions sur la lecture de chevet
préféré de chacun des candidats autre
détail on dit dernier débat
officiellement c'est le com et on m'a
confirmé un coup parti conservateur on
songe peut-être organiser un autre débat
parce que quand même une phrase de 3
moore en ce débat 6 et le 10 septembre
donc et semble-t-il que que c'est dans
la vente des bois très très très
intéressant parce qu'au québec
évidemment ça va être sujet dans les
autres communautés est francophone
du canada ça va être suivie et genre de
voir comme un jean charest vont réussir
à ça à s'en sortir par rapport à bien
polis et qui va encore une fois être
très très très agressif et je me demande
si on n'assiste pas tranquillement un
espèce de perte de momentum de pierre
poilievre qui se marginalise de plus en
plus avec quelqu'un
vous accélérez café trop michel david
ses fans échoué d'un michel d'abord on
espère que le format les règles vont
voter un petit peu plus intéressante
mais mais ça va être un débat assez
pénible dans la mesure où il ya quatre
des six candidats qui parlent pas
français alors essentiellement ça va
être monsieur charest monsieur poignard
et mais c'est important parce que
monsieur charest doit absolument faire
le plein de votes au québec s'il veut
avoir une chance de compenser pour la
vence de monsieur poilievre ailleurs
alors gros enjeu stéphanie on espère que
ça sera pas une seconde foire d'empoigné
entre monsieur charest et monsieur
poilievre parce que ça risque d'être les
deux qui vont dominer du fait que ce
sont les deux seuls qui parlent
réellement français très bien merci
beaucoup à vous trois 20h et redit
qu'ils diffusent ce débat ce soir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit